hello reject nation it's greg alba here
and i'm john debbie Kawai shabby Kawai
is the brother okay so today we are
going to watch a trailer for Slenderman
have you played Slenderman I have not
have you played slender man John no
isn't it just called slender I've played
video games John's trying to question me
right now before we go into this guys I
wanted to give a quick thank you to our
video sponsors Stardust in case you guys
don't know it's an app that allows you
to thirty second reaction turning film
TV show or trailer jab Iike ways on it
he post plenty of videos on there
Tyrone Magnus is on it flick pics on it
Jeremy Jones is on it but you should
download and follow us first before you
follow him download our leak not the jab
eco a one-hour Lee and he has an
American channel too by the way I forgot
to mention that JV TV follow him there
if you feel like it
no no it's required it's required in
order to watch the rest of this video it
comes with your subscription package to
the real reach
[Music]
where is my daughter people who just
disappear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow right there give me right there
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
what's in her hand
[Music]
anything a babies laughter and make that
creepy that's just how don't you take a
baby's laughter and make that crude
babies are among the creepiest they're
only second to children in terms of
creepy I was upsetting the knife and the
I think certainly made me jolt
unexpectedly because everything else was
like okay I can handle this and then the
knife thing happened I'm like nope
that for some reason that just that met
my threshold of like unsettling do you
not like horror I wouldn't say I'm like
a huge horror fan but I'll watch it as a
horror fan myself I think this looks
pretty cool actually then I think did I
just go to some downvotes cuz I said I
don't watch her regularly no no no no no
we get down boats no matter what we do I
thought there's a lot of really cool
shots in this trailer what I was kind of
thinking this might just be a cliche
horror adaptation I don't remember what
came first think it was some tale and
then there was like games and the reddit
post
oh yeah there's even a documentary about
this it started out as a creepy photo
competition on something Awful's message
board then it became this creepypasta
story that kind of galvanized the
Internet then it became a bunch of
webseries then it became a game and then
it became a movie with Doug Jones for a
second this is one of the few
creepypasta stories from the internet
that actually has this somewhat
traceable origin which is how this
movies possible basically well yeah I
mean from what we're seeing here I like
that they're building up this mythology
of it but it's more than just Slenderman
just keeps appearing Slenderman just
keeps apparent it kind of reminds me of
like it's a more psychological version
of Evil Dead more than just Slenderman
is scary there's things that go on
within the characters minds that kind of
cause them to become a little bit
deranged a little crazy start harming
themselves sort of harming others even
though that's a horror trope I like a
lot of the way the cinematography is and
I wonder if this director has like a
music video background or something I
was gonna say the last third of it felt
very experimental film yeah there's this
guy I met while working on a commercial
casting job who apparently directed John
Malkovich and a lot of shorts there was
a lot of that like very experimental
time-lapse stuff that is unsettling to
watch just in its nature you don't yeah
any story or context is just alone
seeing that just makes you uncomfortable
I feel like for Slenderman to be
or a movie this looks like it can be
pretty effective yeah one is a fan of
creamy pasta and having followed this
story for a good amount of time you know
since it I've actually kind of been
following the Slender Man idea for the
time it's been German isn't it called
slender that's the game the video no but
the thing is this means always waiting
for the whole time as they call slender
slender man dude this is a video game
the thing is having watched it grow from
like oh here's a creepy photograph and
now it's taken on so many different
shapes it seems like this trailer kind
of borrowed from everything I know about
the different iterations of Slender Man
there's a certain motif that comes up in
Marble Hornets and and in some of the
lore about what it psychologically does
to you it kind of deteriorates your your
existence over time while it kind of
urges you to do these things depending
on who's mythology you go by and yeah a
lot of those images a lot of those
flashes of weird medical/surgical grainy
you know surreal footage some of that
comes out of those things like Marble
Hornets they had a second youtube
channel that was all like weird
experimental unsettling videos yeah so
it's cool to me that they're borrowing
from everywhere with this I guess cuz
it's comprehensive that way and the only
thing now I wonder is are they gonna
take the real life there were some
murders that happen with a couple of
young girls because of the Slender Man
like for realsies yeah yeah and there's
documentary out about that so I'm
wondering it's some of you yeah some of
this made me think of that too how much
of everything they're gonna draw in from
I guess so like on one end of the
spectrum you have Slenderman starting
for the internet the other end is [ __ ]
my dad says because it's the internet
campfire tale like creepypasta they're a
bunch of them in there everywhere it's a
popular phenomena yeah and they just
grow out of nowhere and become these
Internet phenomena yeah well I hope that
this movie is just nothing but cool
visuals I hope there's no actual story
I hope it's actually Aria Jersey cuz it
can easily not be well I mean that's the
thing is this is this makes for a great
trailer yeah because of the way it's ah
there's not a
into ad characters in this movie their
trailer is this more of a teaser I think
it's a teaser for a debut trick you
didn't get away with things like that if
it's just yeah yeah I know but at the
same time that I'm like there's a lot of
people that are cutting around you in
this movie is there gonna be a cohesive
story because a lot of this can be very
ineffective and just cruel shot this is
kind of fascinating to me to see how
this is gonna take shape cuz they've
been talking about this and arguing over
the legality and the possibility of it
for so long and now that it's here it is
one of those things to me where I am
really fingers crossed hoping that they
took their time took care because this
is a huge cultural phenomenon as a huge
ghost story and it's the kind of thing
that can easily be packaged into a wrote
you know spook movie or it could be
really cool and I hope they use what is
special about it to make it really cool
perfect date movie oh yeah well guys
slender the movie is out soon this year
hopefully my Screen Gems who did one of
my favorite movies snatched so you know
it's gonna be a good movie guys you can
subscribe to the reel rejects you can
click that notification bell make sure
to download and follow us the real
rejects not Jabbok away first on the
stardust app and check out jabby TV on
the youtubes yes he has a really
thriving international channel so good
right now I'm so happy for him yay but
he has an American channel that he just
relaunched and you guys should check it
out a lot of great videos that the real
rejects is crushing by the way but yeah